[Musica]
buona sera io vi parlerò di confini
dello spazio nel tempo e nell'universo
in 12 minuti di pensa un po cominciando
con cominciando con questo modello
geocentrico che dobbiamo tolomeo estote
le è noto a tutti penso alla terra e al
centro
tutti i pianeti sono intorno pensati
come se fossero incastonati come
diamanti su sfere di cristallo che si
muovevano e giravano regolarmente almeno
nella visione aristotelica una visione è
affascinante
ora dobbiamo pensare che oggi nel nostro
le nostre città con tanti inquinamento
luminoso
la vista del cielo delle stelle ci
sembra quasi così una vista mi tanto gli
dedichiamo attenzione per un momento ma
pensate una volta nel buio assoluto
vedere la volta celeste la via lattea
bellissimo e vedere tutte le stelle
muoversi regolarmente nel cielo e chiaro
che come diceva aristotele questo era il
segno di una natura diversa da quella
terrestre dove tutto invece è irregolare
dove tutto è transitorio invece questa
regolarità assoluta è il segno di una
natura differente la natura terrestre le
cose che accadevano qui nel fango erano
diverse dalla natura celeste che era
invece perfetta
ecco tutto questo cambia con quest'uomo
che tutti sappiamo essere galileo
galilei e con questo strumento
uno strumento che è il telescopio
galileo non inventa il telescopio il
telescopio fu inventato da parte
olandese ma diciamo era un po un
giocattolo si usava per per esempio
cominciare a vedere non so le bandiere
delle navi all'orizzonte prima che
potessero essere risolto nudo oppure i
movimenti del nemico nel campo
avversario
lui invece
lo perfeziona questo giocattolo e lo
rende uno strumento scientifico lo
perfeziona come una perizia da da
artigiano rinascimentale lasciatemi dire
è che cosa fa osserva e le sue
osservazioni delle porta su un notebook
diremmo oggi sul suo quaderno
ecco io adesso vi mostro una pagina
autografa di galileo galilei e delle sue
osservazioni
un certo giorno di gennaio del 1610
stiamo per vedere la cartografia di
galileo a di 7 di gennaio 1610 giove si
vedeva col cannone cannone è la forma
ora se ci pensiamo bene cannocchiale è
un cannone occhiale e quindi il sia un
diminutivo che gli da galileo al cannone
e tre stelle fisse così una due e tre
e questa è jupiter reti rai jupiter cioè
lui deve e dice anche delle quali senza
il cannone ognuna si vedeva fa una
scoperta
nessuno in questo cielo considerato
perfetto incontaminato dove tutto quello
che si era visto era già stato segnato
fin dai babilonesi lui vede cose nuove
che nessuno aveva visto prima vede tre
nel vicine vicino a giove continua il
giorno dopo a 18 appariva così questa e
giove e meraviglia le tre stelline si
sono mosse sono tutte da un'altra parte
adesso sanno ancora vicino giove ma sono
tutte spostate e lui dice anche che di
moda diretta e non retrogrado come
dicono i calcolatori che sono
evidentemente ricevono i calcoli sulla
posizione delle stelle a di nove erano
volo punto
a di dieci si vedeva così una due e
vedete la terza è occultata da giove
insomma lui si rende conto che queste
stelline ruotano intorno a giove è la
cosa è stupefacente poi ne vede anche
una quarta alle notti dopo li chiama i
satelliti medicei per ingraziarsi la
famiglia medici che gli serviva in
qualche modo questi quattro satelliti
medicei ruotavano intorno a giove lui si
rende conto di questo e questo perché
perché è straordinario perché allora le
sfere delle sfere di cristallo non ci
sono queste quattro celine l'avrebbero
infrante altrimenti ma di più
qui c'è un piccolo sistema solare in
miniatura il grande pianeta si permette
vini mare il sole che nel modello
copernicano che allora faceva fatica
ancora a imporsi era il centro
dell'universo già ovvero un piccolo
centro per conto suo
per di più questa osservazione vedete
era molto in favore ipotesi di copernico
perché una delle critiche si faceva
copernico cioè al fatto che la terra si
muovesse intorno al sole e del sole che
stava fermo non lo sapete
secondo copernico e secondo anche
galileo che credeva a quest'ipotesi la
terra si muovevano lo spazio ma allora
dicevano se la terra si muove come che
la luna non rimane indietro come che la
segue
ecco ma qui questi tre satelliti di
giove docilmente seguivano il pianeta
che evidentemente si muove ma nel cielo
ecco insomma questa questa scoperta
segna un veramente una rottura una
rottura di un confine il confine tra il
mondo celeste e il mondo terrestre che
non sono di natura diversa perché quello
che si vede lì intorno a giove è una
manifestazione della gravità così come
quella che si manifesta con la loro
intorno alla terra quindi quel dire è
già un primo segno di quella che si
chiamerà poi con
l'universalità della gravitazione
funziona laggiù
forse proprio come funziona anche qua
giù e tutti oggi possiamo con un
telescopio che possiamo comprare a poche
centinaia di euro
possiamo far osservare la questa questa
cosa che vide galileo ed è un'esperienza
che vi invito a fare perché si vede
esattamente sip si prova a questa
emozione di vedere questi pianetini
quasi in fila un pulitissimi dentro in
fila intorno a questo intorno al grande
pianeta
ma che dire però forse il confine più
importante che è stato abbattuto un
altro perché vedete nella visione di
tolomeo e di galileo e di susa tedescò
tele quella mappa con la terra al centro
e tutti i pianeti in fondo e poi c'era
la sfera delle stelle stellate l'empireo
figlio non era questo l'atteggiamento
voglio dire non era quello questo è
quello che sappiamo oggi l'atteggiamento
era questo è tutto quello che c'è da
sapere
non c'è altro per cui la scoperta più
importante
con questa osservazione è la scoperta
dell'ignoranza
non è vero che sappiamo tutto e non è
vero che se una cosa non l'ha detta
aristotele o non è scritta su qualche
libro autorevole allora non è allora non
ci dobbiamo porre un problema vero
l'osservazione diretta può mettere in
discussione qualsiasi opinione del
passato ecco questo è il punto
fondamentale in cui nasce la la scienza
moderna e direi che ancora di più è un
punto di non ritorno perché da allora
armati di questo atteggiamento
dell'atteggiamento del fatto che non è
vero che sappiamo tutto siamo ignoranti
possiamo conoscere di più
e chissà cosa c'è più in là di quel
confine armate di questo atteggiamento
abbiamo scoperto quanto è immenso
l'universo abbiamo visto stelle galassie
sappiamo che tutto l'universo è fatto
delle stesse elementi
per esempio perché abbiamo esaminato
questa radiazione che ci viene da
lontano anche gli stessi elementi
chimici che sono qui sulla terra che
compongono noi sappiamo deve essere di
essere in un universo in universo unico
è tutto questo è nato in quel momento
con questa osservazione con quest'uomo
che ha usato tale il telescopio nel
cielo sapete c'era una persona che
quando puntava sulla luna che si vedeva
benissimo anche con un binocolo e si
vede questa palla sospesa nel vuoto
ecco c'era chi ponendo l'occhio sul
telescopio di galileo si ritrae era
inorridito
ma perché perché quello che vedeva
rimandava a un discute di noi in realtà
è questo quello che succede
attraversando il confine
capiamo finalmente forse un po meglio
chi siamo veramente gli stessi pensate
effettivamente a questa questo quartetto
di thomas stearn eliot che dice non
cesseremo di esplorare e alla fine
torneremo da dove siamo venuti e
conosceremo il posto per la prima volta
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]